I know!
There he is!
Yo, Mozart!
I got to hear one of your songs.
You know, your K. 280 is pretty good!
Mr. Ajino chose Kai.
Hm?
Ichinose?
Ajino!
You've got some nerve showing up
here after skipping today.
Did you come to see me?
No way!
I just came here to look at Mozart!
-Is that Mozart?
-Huh?
No, I mean...
This man is... um...
Beethoven!
Here is one of Beethoven's songs.
This is called "Für Elise."
This is his "Symphony No. 5," known
as "Destiny" here in Japan.
I know that one!
Then what about this guy?
That's Chopin.
Chopin!
Chopin has many famous songs.
For example,
"Waltz in D flat major, Op. 64, No. 1"
"The Minute Waltz."
Chopin!
So this is... Chopin!
That was so cool!
Play it again! Play it one more time!
You like Chopin?
Yeah, that was awesome!
I see.
Wanna give it a try?
What are you talking about?
I can't play it.
No need to be modest.
-You should have it memorized already.
-Huh?
If you can play the song you did
in the forest, then you can play this.
I can only play the piano in the forest.
I can't play normal pianos.
Ah, I see.
The piano in the forest
is special after all.
Once you get the hang of it, you'll be
playing normal pianos in no time.
Why don't you try playing Chopin
on this piano?
I'll watch you.